am 9 juli 2015 musterten 193 soldaten
und soldatinnen von daher des
unteroffiziers akademie zur truppe aus
nach der ernennung zum wachtmeister
folgte die ausmusterung am stadtplatz in
enns der bundesminister überreichte der
lehrgangs besten frau wachtmeister
kerstin neidhardt vom jägerbataillon 25
aus klagenfurt ein ehrengeschenk
der bundesminister magister der eindruck
betonte der soldatenberuf muss letztlich
den stellenwert erhalten
denn unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
aller dienstgrade aufgrund ihrer
hervorragenden leistungen auch verdienen
sehr geehrte damen und herren und
offiziere
sie haben die grundausbildung zum
unteroffizier des österreichischen
bundesheeres erfolgreich abgeschlossen
ich gratuliere ihnen dazu mit größter
anerkennung und persönlichem respekt